Luke Tom and Napier at the outdoor boy's
YouTube channel and today we're doing
the ice bucket challenge to raise
awareness of all the people who have
been injured attempting to raise
awareness online yes every year
thousands of people are seriously
injured in an attempt to raise awareness
and in order to help bring attention to
their suffering we're gonna do the ice
bucket challenge to raise awareness of
people being injured raising awareness
are you guys ready to do this yeah all
right okay you ready
[Music]
so people please like and share and
click Subscribe and remember be aware
that raising awareness can cause
injuries thank you if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]